social networks for example
sure because it feels like really good
transformer models that
are able to do some kind of
like very good natural language
generation are the same kind of models
that could be used
to learn human behavior and then
manipulate that human behavior to
gain advertiser dollars and all those
kinds of things sure
uh feed the capitalist system and and
they arguably already are manipulating
human behavior
yeah yeah so but not for
self-preservation
which i think is a big that would be a
big step
like if they were trying to manipulate
us to convince us not to shut them off
i would be very freaked out but i don't
see a path to that from where we are now
they they
they don't have any of those abilities
that's not what they're trying to do
they're trying to keep people on on the
site but see the thing is this this is
the thing about life on earth
is they might be borrowing our
consciousness and sentience like
so like in the sense they do because the
creators of the algorithms
have like they're not you know if you
look at our body yeah okay
we're not a single organism we're a huge
number of organisms with like tiny
little motivations we're built on top of
each other
in the same sense the ai algorithms that
are they're not it's a system that
includes
human companies and corporations right
because corporations are
funny organisms in and of themselves
that really do seem to have
self-preservation built in and i think
that's
at the at the design level i think
they're designed to have
self-preservation be
a focus so you're right in that in that
broader
system that we're also a part of
and can have some influence on uh
it's it's it is much more complicated
much more powerful yeah i agree with
that
you